[Music]
hey there it's Monday this is GameSpot
daily the show where we cover the top
news stories in 30 minutes or less today
probably less I'm Callie I'm Troy my
Michael hi um hi we had a case of the
giggles damn it's getting too old for
this man it's uh you know tough in the
streets y'all it is it sure is yeah but
we do have news to cover some stuff from
over the weekend you might have heard
but we do want to talk about and some
newer stuff starting with something that
we talked about in the teaser forum last
week so this shows a little bit that's
about 15 minutes you know what else is
about 15 minutes ahahaha this Uncharted
fan film starring Nathan Fillion yeah
what was your initial headline that you
pitched for for this video I my headline
was Nathan Fillion made a self insert
insert Uncharted fan fiction movie and
that is kind of what it is I know what
it is so last week Nathan Fillion was
teasing something with that 7:16 with
the the strain the drink picture with
Drake we talked about this last week but
this is what it is a 15 minute fan film
that he made starring himself as Nathan
Drake smells like self-aware the opening
text does make it clear that it is a fan
fan film not an official so this isn't
like endorsed by naughty dog or Sony or
anything like that so it's straight up
we're gonna play a little bit of it here
so you can check it out while we talk a
little bit about it cuz I watched it
this morning when I came into the
offices like I should probably watch
this you watched it and several people
came up to talk to you about other
things and you kept having to pause it
yeah sure didn't help the movie going
really didn't didn't care all that much
but yeah like you mentioned it stars and
Nathan Fillion as Nathan Drake and if
you follow Nathan Fillion oh no you'll
recognize him from Firefly and Castle
and then so Stephen Lang plays Sully and
he looks slowly looks very old in this
movie I don't think he'll pop up in the
b-roll quite yet cuz this is 15 minutes
but Sully is a little bit older and uh
Mercia more Monroe is that how you say
your name
sure I think that's right okay yeah and
then so she plays Elena Fisher and you
may recognize her from book club and
Magic Mike Magic Mike a very good film
well yeah we could go on and on about
Magic Mike the merits of that that fine
film so yeah it's it's got everything
you'd want an uncharted movie condensed
into 15 minutes so it starts with with
Nathan Drake captured and interrogated
by some bad guys yeah some bad guys I
just called him Nathan squared because
that's what he is
yeah it's to Nathan's make one and of
course is captured by bad guys we can
skip ahead gonna go on there there so
there's silly rules got now but yeah so
it's got he breaks away from being
captured and he starts punching dudes of
course and he finds some old documents
that leads to some highly coveted
treasure or some mystery some hints as
to where this highly covered treasure is
and you know Drake Sully and Elena find
the next stop and you know it at the end
and I'm gonna spoil it they end up
wanting to go to the Philippines I'm
like bro I want to go to the Philippines
the hell yeah take me take a drink so I
don't know I think this is cute he's
very aware that this is what people the
people wanted yeah what's him as Nathan
Drake and now you can stop asking I'm
sure I'm sure he was like please stop
asking me fine I'll just make this
15-minute movie with a high production
value oh yeah anyway I mean Nathan
Fillion is he's he's got a name so I
imagine that he's not going to anything
doesn't doesn't have high production
value he's still he's on it yeah I don't
know what kind of budget they had but
this is if you consider taking into
consideration that's a fan film like
this is pretty damn good
oh yeah but I mean it's still like
choreography alone yeah it's it's fine
the door towards the end it gets really
[ __ ] like it's a real campy it's yeah
it's fine it's it's pretty cheesy but
you know what can you expect it's it's
fun lean into it yeah yeah well yeah
there you have it that's what Nathan
Fillion was teasing last week yeah and
it happened yeah you can check it out
it's on YouTube you can watch it for
free it's not like anyone's gonna charge
you so unless Sony takes it down which
we hope not oh yeah we'll see we'll see
how that plays out but uh I mean it's
it's your boy Nathan Fillion
and just you can't just do that to him
after all the effort and work you in and
see you yeah I'm really curious it's not
clear if he got like you know quiet
approval to do it either oh right right
I wonder how that would play out it
feels like a two-hour film because like
15 minutes you can it's there's like a
course is a cliffhanger there's no like
full story arc within 15 minutes but if
they did do the whole thing it's like
well then you have to go to like
tropical location they would have to I
guess they would shoot in the
Philippines they they would have to do a
lot mmm and and we don't know if it's
monetized I don't know if it's monetized
on YouTube either which would compete
alright quick yep anyway so that's that
there you have it uh-huh watch it if you
would like to yeah it's pretty on
YouTube alright next up we got something
a little more serious this is from last
week but we wanted to talk about it
Rainbow six siege players are now
instantly banned for using slurs well
it's well you'll see it's not always an
instant perma ban but there is a new
instable system live now which affects
any user who uses hate speech the first
offence removes them from all parts of
the game for 30 minutes second and third
offenses get them a two hour band
actually I don't know about this I don't
know if it's actually a progressive band
system so I my understanding is that
there's just different levels of band
that you can get depending on the
severity of offense
so ranging from 30-minute bands usually
for the first offense to a permanent ban
after an investigation on Yousaf send so
that is my understanding of it because I
looked at this yesterday but but
basically don't say slurs and then you
won't have a problem really bad it's
very simple if you're out there playing
playing Rainbow six and you're wondering
why you get banned for saying a slur
don't say it it can be it could be a
learning process alright yeah like you
know Rainbow six siege is a great game
and you know there's there's shitty
people all across the world and so if
you say shitty things you'll face the
consequences so thank you Ubisoft for
doing this yeah they know it's not a
flawless system of course but Ubisoft
will make changes to it over time on
twittered they said quote fighting
against toxicity and cleaning up the
siege environment is a very real and
important issue and then a another
quote no system is perfect but it is
working as intended in a majority of
cases we've been seeing yes and they
also continued say that this is not our
final update for dealing with toxicity
we will continue to observe and make
changes and expansions as needed mm-hmm
UB stated in its stated its three
pronged approach to tackling toxicity
back in April the quote we have is to
track negative player behavior manage
those that behave poorly and eventually
implement features that will encourage
players to improve their behavior which
would include not using slurs I know
some people are like well what if I was
just joking it's not a joke it doesn't
matter it's not funny
I don't matter um it's just not funny
you're making it an alienating place I
mean we've all been in a position I
think we've all been teenagers probably
unless you currently are I sure hope we
have but like I was a teenager and I
didn't understand necessarily like why
certain words were bad right and but
sometimes you're alienating people or
worse
you're just saying [ __ ] you shouldn't be
saying yeah it's not cute it's not funny
so yeah they're doing yeah I'm so glad
so like everyone who's mad if you mad
about this stay mad and if and if you
happen to run into this problem you're
like oh what I you're generally curious
that's like why this is you know it's
like I said it could be a learning
process you know take a step back okay
well maybe I should take something into
consideration that I had wouldn't have
otherwise you know I'm really bothered
by Jake wearing the yellow flannel to a
yellow background yeah there's a they
look like bumblebees black yellow back
and yellow black again oh my god yeah I
like that
we have gameplay of C's but it like in
between um anyway yeah so we I think
here at GameSpot daily are happy that
that Ubisoft is taking this step
obviously they'll continue to iterate
upon the system yeah yeah Blizzard also
said that they want to similar a similar
system for overwatch which I think it
could definitely use and also then um
something about fallouts every six
I think you wrote a piece because the is
also cracking down on this right when I
interviewed Pete Hines at e3 he talked
about how in fallout b6 they they want
to implement ways basically it sounds
like you can opt into PvP stuff so Pete
Hines described it like in fallout 4 if
you see a deathclaw you can fight the
death claw and if you die you can either
try again or walk away okay um decide
you know I'm not level up enough for
this I'm gonna walk away and he said
that he wanted they wanted the fallout
76 PvP to work similarly so you can if
you're not having fun anymore
you'd be like tapping out and done okay
I don't know exactly how that's gonna
work but I think it's a cool idea that
you can basically consent to PvP right
right and you know somebody can't really
troll you because you can just say nope
I'm done yeah
it's nice to see developers you know
take toxicity into consideration when
they build their games because it ain't
no fun when you know people are being
shitty to you and yeah you should
shouldn't do it and like they have to
have systems in place that just get in
front of that man can only get better I
suppose yeah because then in a way this
also makes the shitty people like snitch
on themselves so be better yep be better
all right so there's that there are you
moving on whoo this one's a doozy Secura
shadows die
twice's revive mechanic that's a lot of
s's means it might be even harder then
souls born games I'm gonna say that
again because it's a lot of work yes
sure Sakura shadows die twice has a
revive mechanic that might mean it could
be harder than souls born games okay yes
that is a lot to process so I understand
yeah this is from the official
PlayStation Blog but they did an
interview with secular director he taka
Miyazaki and means like he previously
said that Sakura's combat could be more
challenging than a Souls born games this
time he addressed how the resurrection
mechanic can be used to make the game
tougher yeah okay and I'll read this
quote from Rocky himself
I imagine this was translated I
also did an interview with Miyazaki so
it's translated but he said this there
is Heligan okay there's one thing I'd
like to make sure isn't misunderstood
the resurrection system was not
introduced to make the game easier if
anything it can actually make the game
harder because it allows us to push the
edge of risky combat combat where the
player can die at any moment you don't
necessarily need to go back every time
you die this helps to balance that out
and allows for the riskier edge of the
knife type of gameplay mm-hmm he also
said the system itself is not yet 100%
final so we don't want to say anything
that might end up changing what we can
say is that it's in a place to maintain
the tempo of the game and the difficulty
of the game will be based around it just
because you have this resurrection
mechanic it doesn't mean the player
won't be afraid of death I love the
emphasis like don't worry this isn't
baby mode yeah you could die anytime die
at any moment I was gonna say nevermind
that's all right I already already I
already messed that up
throughout the show but whatever okay
we'll get over it all right yeah there's
a lot of quotes from Miyazaki from this
this blog I guess we can read through
more of them and before time runs out
for the show yeah you spoke about combat
how it'll be different from souls born
games I'll imagine you're wondering
about that if you're interested in
second row he said there are only there
are two types two key things about
battle in second row in combat one of
the key aspects that's important in this
game is the violence of the clashing of
swords the other thing is for
verticality and dynamic movement that
you're allowed so if you've played dark
souls soul and blood-borne you know that
you're kind of stuck to the ground it's
more about bobbing and weaving but here
it's like almost like tension like where
you can like jump on rubes and you can
jump and it's it's a little bit more
acrobatic I would say mm-hmm by the way
we're watching the e3 trailer for Sakura
I think anyway he also says that
dynamism is in the combat as well there
are lots of different ways to approach a
battle such as stealth or using your arm
tools attacking from above for example
some of your ninja tools can take
advantage of an enemy's weakness as well
or if you want you can just go straight
in with your sword so flexibility that's
cool yeah
do we want to keep reading more quotes
you could probably read checkout yeah
you know how to read probably yeah so
you can go check out that was a that
whole interview is on PlayStation Blog
yes so you can check that out if you're
very interested in second row shouts I
twice I know I am so I did read through
that bang
yeah but the interview headline is
interview Miyazaki on the limbs and lore
of Socorro shadows die twice so if
you're interested in reading more and
not having us do a bedtime story read
through to you I'm into bedtime stories
totally into bed you know let us know in
the comments if you would rather us give
you a nice bedtime story it's it's the
morning though like I don't know if
y'all want to see it's night somewhere
yeah I suppose it is night and over in
the UK so tomorrow if your watch some
more of your watching I hope this is a
lovely bedtime story because I know how
much you I'll put you the layered love
Japanese history that's a good song I
like that alright we have one minute
what I want to say in our one minute I
do want to shout out Jake Decker who you
saw in the the black and yellow check
shirt to the video interview with Mike
pon Smith the creator of cyberpunk 2020
it's really cool it's beautifully edited
this this interview but it's all about
the the allure in the world of cyberpunk
and the cyberpunk universe and of course
cyberpunk 2020 serves as the inspiration
for 2077
CD Projekt Reds next game and Mike Pond
Smith is working closely with them on
that he also talked about like his
reaction to the trailer for cyberpunk
2077 so it's really cool and it's on
YouTube now so check that out yeah Mike
Pond Smith is a he's a character his
voice is so lovely to listen he's he's
real good
I like him a lot the comments are like
he sounds like god please do it's very
good work Jake does very good work and
yeah he's it's probably like the most
excited he's been for a game in forever
so he puts in a lot of work there so you
could check out his feature on cyberpunk
oh and then we should probably shut out
that the stream is animated a black over
black clover Erik Tay is heading up our
live stream at 11:30 a.m. Pt if you're
watching live
so it's on a little bit after this they
are streaming black clover which is in
like closed beta right now briefly
during a brief window of time today and
then it'll go dark until release
something like so if you're interested
in the black clover game I think it's
black clover quartet Knights I think is
the title something like that check that
out we'll be streaming that shortly
after this yes all right well let's give
some thanks before we go I want to thank
me I want to thank you I wanna thank
Matt Tony I want to thank Chris I want
to thank tomorrow and I don't thank you
thank you for watching
we'll be back every day we are back
tomorrow of course Tuesday well you're
not back but I am oh I forgot yeah I
won't be here Tuesday and Wednesday I'm
doing so it's you I'm gonna be playing
some football he's gonna be doing I mean
I don't I can't know if I can talk about
it but you'll be say yeah I'll be
playing some football yeah so we will be
back though I will be back with a guest
to be determined yeah tomorrow all right
we'll see you then for more news thank
you for watching bye bye